le petit nicolas et ses amis n'ont
jamais cessé d'avoir 18 ans lé héros
inventé par goscinny et sempé nous
embarque dans de nouvelles aventures
un livre de plus de 600 pages qui
rassemble ces histoires inédites sort
dans quelques jours en avant-première et
cher tripots et de nos villes nous le
présente près de 650 pages et des
aventures qui fleure bon les cours de
récréation et les tartines de confiture
voilà donc 80 histoire du petit nicolas
inventé par rené goscinny qui reviennent
quarante ans après leur première
publication dans le journal sud ouest
dimanche et pilotes qui me colle est
alors normal c'est à dire il est
gourmand il est bagarreur il aime jouer
au football et il aime s'amuser
ceci dit il est très gentil le gentil
petit nicolas et sa bande dessinée
croqué par le pont plus de rené goscinny
jean jacques sempé des enfants qui ont
toujours 8 quand il ya la alceste le
gros qui mange tout le temps clotaire le
dernier de la classe e 2 qui aime la
bagarre et bien sûr agnan le chouchou de
la maîtresse un univers d'enfant tendre
et espiègle que anne goscinny a
récemment retrouvé dans les archives de
son père
c'est un monde idéal exempt de violence
d'agressivité complètement ces deux de
méchanceté à la limite on se prend un
coup de poing sur le nez parce que des
très forts et quand les parents se
disputent n'y a pas de divorce dans
l'air après ils se réconcilient puis à
une chouette tarte aux pommes donc c'est
un monde idéal c'est presque un monde de
compte ces histoires du petit nicolas
décrivent un monde ancien celui des
années 50 et 60
un univers familial scolaire dans lequel
malgré tout les enfants d'aujourd'hui se
retrouvent les écoles ont changé les
bureaux ont changé la tenue a changé
mais paradoxalement ce qui m'étonne
c'est que les enfants de maintenant
quand ils lisent
comprennent tout et ça leur est familier
c'est la raison pour laquelle le petit
nicolas est devenu au fil des années
l'écolier le plus célèbre de la
littérature car quand on a entre 8 et 12
ans et même s'il a aujourd'hui plus de
40 ans nicolas est quand même un copain
drôlement chouette